et
[Musique]
c'est west ham et onenote et
une de ses balles et comme nous et
voyage à travers le temps en marche
avant l'autre bar marche arrière
vous pouvez les différencier
et maintenant
[Musique]
quoi ça fait si blizzard vous ne tirez
pas à la malle vous la recevez
pour notre cinéma chaque année
c'est qui cet américain il a l'air
sympathique jeu les invités au dîner
il a un bon coup de boule diplomate
il y a des gens dans l'avenir qui ont
besoin de nous
[Musique]
tu penses à un moyen tu vas ticket
le problème ce n'est pas la durée c'est
ressortir en vie
quand ça apporte
il
[Musique]
m
comment
[Musique]
cette page a dit aman
vous imaginez pas dans quoi vous vous
fourrez si vous passez le porte
[Musique]
dirais pas même alors tout tuyaux serait
le bienvenu line au vermont
c'est
on aurait affaire à quoi aude et
bray-dunes car futur
[Musique]
tu veux faire s'écraser un avion est un
avion de quelle taille
ce poids là est légèrement dramatique
la stam et onenote et l'essai